[Music]
clapping me happy to laugh
buenos dias
we have now stopped in Ensenada and it's
so crazy because it immediately as soon
as I opened the door I took in that air
and it smells like Mexico like Mexico
actually has a scent that I really
missed and so smelling this right now
just it's really great I'm just like
I'm back to the motherland it feels
extra special because hey you smell that
because Luca's here and he gets to
experience a little taste a little piece
of Mexico for one day so I don't know
it's really cool this is his first
international trip and we just woke up
it's nine o'clock in the morning like
literally our pjs we'll have my
retainers on and everything
you smell it
you smell Mexico
it's a sense of your land Luca today
we're actually supposed to do like a
wine tasting tour or something that they
booked for us but it's like a four and a
half hour
Excursion and a lot of that time is
spent in the park and then also it's
like a wine tasting thing where we're
like oh well the kids can't really enjoy
it so Casey and I decided to skip it
we're just gonna see what's what's
around and enjoying
my land oh I feel so good to be back I
really really miss Mexico no big deal
[Music]
Lucas still has a step foot in Mexico
yet oh yeah he still has it
thank you
breakfast
[Music]
all right so we walked around and uh
what are we doing now I'm getting my
hair braided
yeah so we were eating and this lady uh
you know she walked up to us and was you
know soliciting and all and she got
kicked out from the restaurant they're
reading at but uh yeah bumped into her
again on the streets and uh she got
herself some business I haven't brushed
my hair so there's like so many knots in
it I'm like sorry oh you want to talk
about what happened with the car seat oh
yeah so yeah so while we were eating the
restaurant gave us some free shots and I
was trying to make room for the oysters
that came later and I shoved some plates
out of the way and then I accidentally
knocked over the one of the shots over
onto the car seat now we're trying to
have the car seat dry in the sun because
it literally smells like Luca it was
boozing while in Mexico
half of his DNA Homeland Mexico
[Music]
[Applause]
step for his family tree all right
what's the finished product here
oh beautiful you look like a beautiful
Mexican Village girl
with a Mexican Village boy and another
Mexican Village boy I could actually do
this myself because I do do it myself
but I'm like why not support a local a
little bit you know and then also just
get my hair out of the way
[Music]
all right we just walked like 10 minutes
out to get to a Mexican bakery
I get some authentic Mexican Concha and
they got an instrumental flavors here it
is awesome give me an Oreo yeah they
have an Oreo and a massive fun shot
you've never seen them
okay what was the yellow one I don't
know this is like Bolo
they're working their magic back there
this place is cool kind of reminds me of
a Chinese Bakery it says we got the
wings back there Don cats over there
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
we're all pirate out for pirate nights
[Music]
where's your shirt
it's a Catalina pirate Pirates of the
Catalina Island all right we're waiting
in lines that means tonight is Pirates
nights
foreign
[Music]
you've learned well there we go all
right so now we're just killing some
time before uh dinner I'm using lunch
before dinner
we're gonna have a whole pirate themed
dinner at the same restaurant we ate
last night
it's really relaxing pretty much all
right so we realized oh I've realized
that Luca loves carrots these carrots in
particular I've been trying to give them
uh chicken broccoli Brad he likes bread
obviously who doesn't like bread but
these carrots are pretty good these jerk
spiced uh carrots these lemonade
Mas
Mass
[Music]
oh you like some carrots
foreign
[Music]
the fireworks show it's also a Pirates
of the Caribbean party I don't know if
you can see that okay you can't see it
but it's all blown out it says Pirates
of the Caribbean party and uh Casey and
Luca stayed in the room because it's way
too cold way too windy it's also way
past Lucas bedtime so they're gonna miss
out unfortunately
wow look at just not I just left the
room and he's already knocked out he was
tired my poor baby but yeah I'm here
with Isaac though
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
[Music]
okay that fireworks show was so cool and
extra special because of the fact that
Disney Cruise Lines is the only approved
cruise to do fireworks at Sea like
that's freaking cool so getting to
experience that was really really
special
it's pretty cool it feels like right in
front of us so I feel like the proper
show yeah we had like the best dude by
the way yeah I don't know I guess maybe
next we're gonna go try to play a little
ping pong and see how well we do because
the ship is moving
there's a lot of chasing after the ball
I love how Uncle West is such a fun
Uncle he's always playing with Luca
[Music]
wow
this afternoon we hope you enjoyed all
this stuff
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed getting to know one
another
[Music]
we're having dinner
he was almost there but she made it yeah
that's her restaurant
there we go she made it she made it
we're here
[Music]
so are you ready to dance
[Applause]
this is a really fun dinner I love it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ha
foreign
[Music]
it is seven o'clock in the morning we
are having our departation breakfast
some we're still waking up though I
accidentally only gave Isaac five
minutes to get ready I let him sleep a
lot anyway we're back at Tiana's place
for breakfast and then that's it we're
done with our Disney week a whole week
of Enchantment and wonder and dreams
coming true like literally I love I just
I love this week it's been amazing super
grateful to be able to be invited to
come out
and enjoy this with my family it's so
grateful it's been such a wonderful
experience like I cannot tell you guys
how wonderful it's been even though
you've seen it you know through this
week with our Vlog like just
experiencing it oh my God super super
great good morning
it's ready to go on you ready to go home
we're literally down to one wife left
and two diapers left like oh my gosh
like barely barely made like tacky
enough for this kid or you packed it
perfectly right
exactly and somehow knew that we're
gonna be left to this
by Disney one day
adios we're back in San Diego
Thank you so much for the amazing
experience we're gonna miss you
hi baby
[Music]